[Music]
where I came from was being sexually
molested as a child you know by my
church janitor in a place where you're
supposed to be safe and that took me to
prison 20 years ago and I got out and I
became a drug and alcohol counselor and
ten years ago I worked in a prison crc
as a drug and alcohol counselor and I
used to teach people how to stay out of
domestic violence relationships and
after 16 years of being clean I woke up
in one and I was like how did I get here
you know and the shame and the
degradation and everything that we go
through and those type of relationships
I mean I gained 85 pounds I was told
that I wasn't worth anything
and all those things that happened to us
they took me back out and I ended up
getting high again after at this time
well it saved my life
this prison term saved my life so 20
years ago I was in prison 10 years ago I
worked in one and 10 years later I was
in one but it saved my life
and I truly believe that there's a time
and a place for everything I was not
ready before now if that makes any sense
I met the actors gang October 18th 2015
I found my bunkie hanging in myself and
I saved her life and the next day I had
some lifers telling me I would have left
her hanging and I didn't want to be that
person I didn't ever want to feel so
hopeless and so devastated and so broken
and so angry and so hurt and so
disappointed that I would feel that way
I wanted to love everybody and I started
the actors gang program from the very
first minute I was there I remember the
very first writing that I did I was
crying and I thought to myself
something's different about this there's
something different about this and the
politics that go on in men's prison is
an
as common in women's prison I've been
told that I'm the first woman to come
out from actors gang and actually come
speak but that's not because there
aren't other women it's because most of
those women are lifers and it's because
one of them specifically who I will not
name because that's not for me to do but
she's been there 46 years and I love her
and she's one of the best teachers there
but it's not because they don't want to
be here it's because they haven't been
given the opportunity to show that their
life has changed I was given seven years
four months
I got 16 months for my crime I got six
years in enhancements for the prison
term that I did 20 years ago so I only
did not only did 25 months and now I'm
in a in a transitional home I'm in a
treatment program and my director
brought me today and I just there was
something when I when I sat with myself
last night and I said what is it when I
was meditating because today I know how
to meditate today I know how to sit down
and I know how to actually close my mind
and I know how to take you know a
checklist what's going on with my body
today I don't want to do that because of
actors game today I know how to
experience things through feelings but I
allow them to exit when it's time you
know before we stay angry we stay hurt
we overcompensate with certain feelings
and it makes us sick and we don't know
how to act when I was doing this
check-in last night and I was telling
myself you know Lord what am I gonna do
what am I going to speak about can you
please give me you know some direction
and it opened up this book and there was
something that was very profound and to
me this they were speaking to me
directly about the actors gang and I
would like to share it with you there is
no such thing as solitary stardom behind
every successful person is a team of
people who helped make that success
possible if you've achieved
achieved success no doubt there are
others who have made sacrifices for you
worked alongside you encouraged you
inspired you given you opportunities and
helped you to mature you have the choice
to celebrate yourself or to luxuriate in
your pride or you can acknowledge
regularly and sincerely the
contributions of others for the sake of
love choose wisely this is what actors
gain does they come in they sit down
with a whole bunch of people that have a
whole multitude of crimes and they tell
you that you're worthy they tell you we
don't care why you're here we just want
you to get better they look at us like
we're people and because of that we
become people because to ourselves
especially when we fail we feel unworthy
but today we don't have to feel that way
as soon as I got out and as soon as I
was allowed I contacted the actors gang
and I said listen I really want to speak
with you I want to advocate with you
because now it's about paying it forward
see it's about given to somebody else
what was so freely given to me and I so
wanted to go to my daughter's graduation
next week she's graduating she's 18 and
she doesn't want me there because she
doesn't want to explain to her friends
where I've been to for two years and
today I will honor her feelings and I
will totally be okay with that but the
first thing that popped in my head I
called Sabra and I said listen this is
what happened and the first thing I
wanted to do was do the work I wanted to
do the work because it taught me how to
experience what I'm feeling and not to
let it own me or define me
[Applause]
so one last thing I want to talk about
is when we do that when we do these
exercises we talk about giving the
audience the food I want to let you know
that as we're standing up there and
we're doing these different states and
we're giving the audience the food
please please know that I'm the one
being fed amen thank you
[Applause]
[Music]